This is awesome!
I'm so scared
*dramatic music*
*nice music*
(HAI GARBLE)
Goooood Morning.
How was that timelapse?
Hopefully good.
Excuse me Garble
Alright.
Thirty bot camera
I don't think it's too bad
I'm curious to use at more places, that was just a test.
But anyway I'm going to the gym now
Which you don't need to know for any reason but..
that's-- that's why I'm vlogging
I'm looking at some of these like  old vintage lenses
And I think some of them will actually fit this camera
Which might be cool.. I don't know
Go full hipster
How do I look now? Beautiful (as always)
Okay, got a new setup, kind of
It's kinda cool
Hopefully its less like in my fucking face
And hopefully it was worth a little bit..extra more money
I'm sure everyone is gonna be like
"Ergh I liked the old one where you were close to the face"
SHUT UP!
SHUT YOUR FUCKING MOUTH!
DON'T TALK TO ME WITH THAT!
Well, well, well
*laughing*
Now that's some good dance
Brad:Hey look at that, that looks like a new lense and a new microphone
A new microphone
Pewds: OH YEAH!
Pewds: Hopefully... try and slap it and see what happens
Brad: Wow, Its completely holographic
*laughing*
*sad music*
SLIPPY!
AAH!
NO!
He's fine
You like this Marzia?
Marzia: No!
Marzia: No more!
No more?
You think that I can do this?
lmao
*laughing*
This is so cool!
So were at Lacma...and were supposed to check out some cool stuff,
I ate too much though, I'm so full.
That's awesome.
*nice music*
We're really lucky to get tickets
We are really
We got the last one!
Oh my god!   We gotta hurry up-- we got five minutes- we gotta be there
I'm excited!
Just looks so cool!
Holy shit!
WTF?
Woah!
That's so cool!
So, you should be able to walk in and the rain will stop.
Look at these people!
I'm going!
Bye Marzia!
Look at all these zombie's!
The zombie walk!
This is so cool!
Oh my god
This is awesome!
I'm so scared
Of the camera.
I'm scared of the camera
I don't care if I get wet
AWW! <3
AWW! x1000000000 <3
That was really cool!
That was so cool!
I'm so glad we got to do that!
We were so lucky to get tickets!
Last minute
literally we ran. ( Leafyishere joke)
What is happening here?
This place just gets weirder and weirder.
We just came for the rain part.
That's how I wish I could drive in LA.
Hey Marzia, I dare you to find me.
Well, whatever
*silence*
(Okay now we're back!)
*Poods giggles*
Security is looking at me like I'm an asshole
My favorite picture
Okay great
That one has to be the best one
Marzia's really into it
Marzia: Yeah
It's cool, right?
Marzia: Look at these
Yeah it's awesome
I know it's just stone but it looks cool
The rain was amazing
Yeah, it was so fun
I like that it was interactive
It was very interactive
Marzia: mmhmm
I really like that, interactive stuff
Marzia: yeah
*sneaky kiss*
Marzia: Let's go!
This is really cool, to walk here
*Marzia giggles*
You wanted to rush home?
* a very cute yeah from Marzia*
Because your picture's gonna break the Internet? (It did)
Is that what you're saying?
Marzia: Yeah
I mean, you guys saw the footage
We're gonna break the Internet
Instagrammmm
is gonna shit
... the Sam?
Marzia: Yeah!
Pewds: Thank you
for backing me up there
*cutscene music*
Ohhhhh
my
god
I don't believe it
A big ass Christmas tree
Too soon, man!
Oh my god there's Santa and the reindeers
Nothing says Christmas like uh, Christmas tree and palm trees in the same shot
This feels like Disneyland
So busy
(HOO MAH GAHD)
*Crazy In Love playing in the background*
People ain't lying-- here to take a picture
Too many people here
I don't know if we can stay here (awww :/)
I don't know what I was ordering
I had like the biggest ice cream ever
How do I eat it?
I don't--
That tasted really great
It's good
My life is over (just like your YouTube channel)
Wha-- (luigi)
Five second rule!
Five second rule
Dammit
First one to play that game
Thank you very much--
Not a big deal or anything, but you know
I'm excited for it
I mean I know it's good because I played it
There it is (awwwww)
Came out--
It came out great
Now I can't wait for everyone to say I have to propose
(You do)
Pressure to propose is on
How about, we just live our own GODDAMN LIFE
And you gon' shut up about it?
Hmm?
We talked about it
I-- I think both me and Marzia kinda feel like
When we want to, we will
But we're still young
We're still
beautiful (and will always be)
What's the rush?
You keep seeing all these young couples getting, getting married way too soon and
you know, it all goes to the shitter
You want that to happen?
Is that what you want?
Don't think so
So until then,
*kiss kiss*
STFU
Omg Brad gets a strike, he's not wearing his shirt
Aw, dammit there he is
Shhhh
I'm about to give her
what she deserves
*Marzia talking in distance*
Hey Marzia, I got a proposal for you
*Ftoop*
Marzia: WHAT!?
*Pewds' very weird giggle*
*Flashback*
Marzia: That really hurts!
Did I really-- ?
Did it really hurts?
I'm so sorry
IM SO SORRY
*apologetic hug*
Marzia: Stop, it hurts
Okay, fine, you get one shot but that, then you can't get mad at me
No
Jeeesus
No, [inaudible] put it down, alright?
Marzia: I will hit you in the neck, like you did--
Pewds: Don't get me in the head
Marzia: Turn around!
DON'T GET ME IN THE HEAD!
*Ftwoop*
Ah!
You tryna shoot my balls!
*another ftwoop*
Oww!
You wanna die!?
Hey, careful
Marzia: -- Santa
Marzia: It's Santa Claus
Oh, it's Santa Claus!?
*Marzia squeals*
NO!
Nooo
Pewds: Cook food!
I am!
Pewds: She looks so scared
Marzia: I am
Marzia: I cook --
Pewds: COOK!
Aww, you cooked for me c:
Thank you Marzia <3
Alright
Today was such a fun day
I hope you enjoyed another day of Birdabo
Had a lot of fun with Marzia <3
And tomorrow's the day shoot for Scare Pewdiepie
So we're gonna start early, at one
We had-- Me and Marzia are gonna relax for a little bit right now (uh huh ;D)
And uhhhh
I'll see you tomorrow, with another episode of Birdabo!
Stay awesome bros